[Music]
everything
hey there welcome to the uplift it's a
show that lifts you up for at least the
next 30 minutes hopefully even longer
than that you and me as well we've got a
great show for you today great cast of
characters as always among them these a
man wanted a friend to go to Disneyland
and he ended up with an unlikely person
going along with him we'll explain a
couple who saved a man in a wheelchair a
wheelchair stuck on train tracks now
they're getting a big gift for that big
rescue and a woman exploring the depths
of the ocean and how she's making
history while she does it plus we're
celebrating an artist who created work
you will definitely instantaneously
recognize which iconic logo that he
design we'll show you and lizzo you know
her well she's making history as well
what she got to do something no one else
has done in 200 years all that and our
heartwarming videos the ones you gotta
see you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
thank you
hey there I am Tony decopo this is the
uplift and we are going to start exactly
where you wish we would a history making
Superstar named lizzo well she just
became part of presidential history as
well Caitlin O'Kane has the story
she's a singer dancer businesswoman and
an avid flute player and now lizzo is
part of presidential history it all
started with an invitation from the
Library of Congress the library is home
to the world's largest flute collection
and knowing lizzo had a love for flutes
her own flu even has its own Instagram
the library invited her to come check
out the collection
including a Priceless 200 year old
Crystal flute that once belonged to
President James Madison
she accepted the offer and visited the
library while in DC for a concert but of
course one Crystal flute stood out James
Madison's flute gifted to him by Claude
Laurent
it's believed only
185 of laurent's glass flutes exist
today
and this one was almost destroyed when
the British invaded Washington DC during
the War of 1812 first lady Dolly Madison
saved the flute from the White House and
now 200 years later it's having its
Renaissance
the library even let lizzo play the
flute at her concert and although she
was a tad nervous to hold the delicate
instrument
[Applause]
she shared the spotlight with the flute
and made history
[Applause]
foreign
musical instruments made to be played
and she knows how to play it all right
to our next story we previously
introduced you to a man named Isaiah
Garza he uses social media for good
performing random acts of kindness for
strangers well Garza recently came up
with a very creative way to make someone
smile it's kind of his trademark you
might say here's CBS Los Angeles is
Lauren Posen with more
you don't know how much I appreciate
this
[Music]
an unforgettable trip to the happiest
place on earth I thought I live at just
about over you know I said I've got noon
right and then as Isaiah comes along 97
year old veteran William good lives in
Southgate he didn't know he'd be going
to Disneyland his caretaker answered an
ad downtown Los Angeles resident and
Tick Tock Creator Isaiah Garza put on
Craigslist it literally was like
something along the lines of college
student looking for senior citizen to
make smile oh my God nelva Aguilar
thought good would be perfect I
submitted two pictures of him with some
shades on and um and another one with
other Shades and then I got a response
from him but I didn't know who he was at
all she was just like he's the sweetest
human being ever you're gonna love him
and I was like listen do not tell him
anything Garza told her to bring good to
a Park this is what happened next I'm
sorry to bother you
um oh I've had a really really rough day
I just wanted to see if you'd be willing
to go to Disneyland with me today hey
that's great you really want to take me
so you don't have to worry about nothing
I'm paying for everything I said oh my
gosh their magical trip has over 1
million views on Tick Tock it just fell
so right when we got on that thing and
he was smiling and I'm like this is
really happening I look over at him and
he's smiling and I just felt like oh man
this is perfect and started a beautiful
friendship between two strangers I'm
going to remember that the rest of my
life
we've got a lot going on in this show
we're also going to Mark Hispanic
Heritage Month by introducing you to an
artist that you may not have heard of
but you will instantly recognize his
work here's Mary Lee with the story
his works are bold striking imaginative
Carlos Perez David is renowned as a
Latino artist he's in the
Mexican-American Hall of Fame less known
is that he's the guy instantly it has to
say that's an apple who drew what maybe
the world's most iconic logo personally
approved by Steve Jobs if I would have
known that Apple would become a two
trillion dollar company I would have
said Steve I'll do your work for free
just give me some stock throughout the
San Francisco Bay area you can see Perez
David's celebration of his Heritage this
mural depicts indigenous cultures most
of his drawings honor his family this is
my idea very proud it gave me the life
to get me to where I'm at today right it
gave me that Foundation the roots of
myself and my culture all in a career
both stunning and biting
eating from the Tree of artistry there
you might say all right coming up meet
the history maker who traveled to the
deepest part of the ocean we'll tell you
what motivated her to take that Journey
plus our heartwarming videos the ones
you just gotta see stick around we're
back in a moment
hey there welcome back to the uplift and
welcome back to those viral videos ones
you just gotta see we stack them up
every week and this one's coming from
Brian Tabler he works at a Doggy Daycare
and he wanted to test his dogs take a
look
let's see what dogs know how to sit at
dog daycare today
hi Daisy can you sit Baby Daisy can you
see it no that's not just the flying
whatever hey Lucy do you want your toy
can you see it sit good job hey oh
Dexter can you see it bro Dexter get
down Sit oh my God good job hey Lola
you're new here can you sit
good job get out of my pocket hey yo
Jerry what do I have to do to get you to
sit dude can you sit Jerry sit bro
Rolo I thought you guys were practicing
at home
[Music]
Sherry's not into it all right our next
video I gets into the subject of what it
takes to get your seat upgraded on a
plane Brittany D'Angelo said she was
waiting for a flight when the gate agent
challenged passengers to a dance contest
best dancer gets that better seat the
upgrade you've seen the dance moves
there as you can see D'Angelo put on her
very best doing the worm wowing the gate
agents and of course
she won
okay I'd give it to her as well
I wouldn't dance for it but there you go
all right a family in Plainfield
Illinois started getting ready for
Halloween and they did it a little bit
earlier this year uh the Apple family
they began decorating their house
not on September 1st not early October
we're talking August 1st
it's all because every year they decided
to go big with their Halloween display
but they really did outdo themselves
this year with a stranger things theme
all but based on the hit Netflix show
they went viral on Tick Tock for their
decorations and for one in particular an
illusion that makes it look like Max
Mayfield's character is hovering in
midair
it's not real it's not a real person
it's just a mannequin but the Apple
family does not want to divulge exactly
how they got this effect so they're not
sharing the secret behind how they did
it I approve I do all right coming up
meet the couple who helped save a man
stuck on train tracks in a wheelchair
imagine that now they are all being
recognized for the steps they took to
Save a Life that day plus what's the
story behind this surveillance video
that shows an animal walking into a
police station
give you the full scoop after the break
a pair of Good Samaritans in Boston
recently rescued a man whose wheelchair
picture this was stuck on train tracks
after that life-saving good deed they
all reunited and they got a big surprise
here's CBS Boston's Paul Burton
nice to meet you it was a day of
surprises and gratitude at Gillette
Stadium thanks to the Patriots
organization we first caught up with JT
earlier this week in Holbrook after Good
Samaritans Matt and Megan Poole rescued
him when his old wheelchair got stuck on
the tracks of an oncoming train all he
wanted that day was a cup of coffee
before the Patriots game today JT's mom
thanked the couple you saved me and my
family a lot of tears from one mother to
the next Honey thank you so much this is
when the surprises began for this
die-hard Patriots fan we wanted to give
you guys a private tour of the Hall of
Fame yeah
and around every turn in the Hall of
Fame JT was filled with joy and laughter
both families have no idea what's about
to happen but they're about to meet
Patriots linebacker and JT's favorite
player Matt judon
[Music]
glad you're here
judon offered both families tickets to
this weekend's home opener versus the
Ravens
and if that wasn't enough with the help
of Judah and the mobility equipment
recyclers out of Rhode Island JT was
presented with a brand new wheelchair
who's your favorite player again
really not much for me more it's more on
these guys that saved them uh and you
know we just kind of heard about the
story and just wanted to help out the
Patriots gave them the tickets and we
came up with enough money to get the man
a wheelchair and something that will
suit him way better we knew that uh he
needed bigger tires so he wouldn't get
caught in the tracks we gave him a cup
holder so that he can put his Mary Lou's
in there somebody's acknowledging the
need
that we've needed for so long it
relieves us to know that now he's safe
I'm so happy he has something that not
only did he need but he's got the
Cadillac Now isn't he riding in style a
simple kind gesture I'm glad you said
can go a long way
in Foxboro I'm Paul Burton WBZ News
that's a great story we're flexible on
that whole Boston Community well done
folks all right next up we're going to
introduce you to a student finishing
College in Minnesota while his family
was back in Ukraine in the middle of the
war there he needed some help and a Good
Samaritan decided to step in here's CBS
Minnesota's David Schumann with that
story
while Nikola sapernoff worked to
graduate from the University of
Minnesota he also watched Russian forces
invade his hometown it's very difficult
because I felt like I had no control of
you feeling really powerless and you
feel like you can't really do much he
needed a place to live too before
starting his grad studies I just jumped
on it it just felt like a gift and
before I knew it we were connecting and
I was sort of offering him everything I
have the daughter of Holocaust Survivors
Margie felt an immediate affinity for
mccola sweetheart I mean you know I just
I love him now their connection led to
something greater Margie's sponsoring
mccola's family to come to America
they're now in Latvia after escaping
Ukraine I'm excited
to know that they're going to be in
safety but it's also you know I feel in
a way responsible for making sure that
this transition is um
you know goes as smooth as possible this
is where McColl and his family will move
into a two-bedroom apartment University
Housing they'll be here in about three
weeks and the to-do list to get the
place ready is about a mile long you
need every Fork spoon sheet you need
everything a post asking for donations
got an overwhelming response when you
make a personal connection Everything
Changes because you start to really care
it's not just some cause out there you
start to care and that brings up
something very beautiful in Us in
Minneapolis I really hope that they will
be able to find themselves here and as I
you know found myself here David Schuman
WCCO 4 News
good people coming together there our
next video is about a peculiar site
captured by a police department security
camera and I mean a very peculiar site
here at CBS Boston's brand Truitt with
this story
yeah he turned himself in he had had
enough uh he was ready to go you've
likely heard of a whale of a tail and
this one involves a seal the folks in
Beverly naming him Schubert after shoe
Pond where he'd been playing for more
than a week it's just Upstream from the
mouth of the ocean he knew to stay from
the boat stay away from the Nets he
would he would come close enough that
they would get some pretty good pictures
of them that's Beverly police chief John
Lasher he says on Thursday the real work
began to try to get him out but Schubert
kept evading police by Sunset Rescuers
called it a night but the seal had other
plans police say around 2 30 Friday
morning Schubert got on the Move
waddling across a shopping Center
parking lot following the fence line to
the front door of the police station
police called in the team at Mystic
Aquarium right away yeah the story just
keeps going when the folks for the
aquarium got here they say they were
taken aback at first they recognized
some of the markings on Schubert's face
turns out he is a repeat offender the
aquarium had to rescue him on the cape
back in 2018. we do know the seal he's
about four or five years old and it's
come full circle he is back where he
started back then but we're gonna be
releasing him as soon as possible
Schubert's original name was Jackal but
Sarah Callan with the Mystic Aquarium
assures me the name Schubert is here to
stay he's getting a checkup in
Connecticut Callan says he looks healthy
and is even getting some time to play
he'll be released back into the ocean
this weekend this time with the GPS
tracker uh luckily Schubert did us all a
favor and brought himself to the police
department which is a story that totally
blows my mind still a journey through
sea stream and Shopping Center parking
lot with a playful Schubert ready to go
home in Beverly Brandon Drew at WBZ News
hey they're there for help even if
you're sealed all right coming up meet
the woman who traveled to the deepest
part of the ocean did not spot shupert
the seal there but made history on her
journey stick around you're watching The
Uplift
[Music]
the Mariana Trench is the deepest spot
in any ocean on earth an oceanographer
Dawn Wright recently explored its depths
making history as she did so Lee Cowan
with the story
in the waters of the Western Pacific
where the color blue was seemingly born
oceanographer Don Wright was a little
blue herself my mother she died in
December she wanted to be able to to
live to to see this but she is watching
from from heaven
the next morning right a specialist in
Marine geology and geography at the
environmental systems Research Institute
would take on the challenge of the
deepest place on Earth I'm actually the
first person of any gender of African
descent to to go to Challenger Deep no
other black person has gone to
Challenger Deep Challenger Deep seven
miles beneath the surface more than six
times deeper than the Grand Canyon
almost triple the depth of the Titanic
it's been seen by so few
sinking that far down isn't the problem
of course it's getting back without
being crushed that's the conundrum and
currently there's only one manned
vehicle in the world that can do it
coming out it's cold limiting factor but
two-person submersible that's the
brainchild of Texas Adventurer and
Explorer Victor viscova enjoy it thank
you
he personally financed its design and
construction if it can work here it can
work anywhere on the sea floor the
trenches in our ocean are largely a
watery black hole in terms of research
but these hard to reach places do have
so much to tell us the Earth's reaction
to climate change for example how we can
better predict earthquakes and tsunamis
perhaps even how life began it's very
cool Wright's tasks will be to bring
back the first high-resolution mapping
of this unforgiving place how much of
the ocean is mapped currently the
current number is 23.4 percent
of the global sea floor not even a
quarter is mapped to sufficient detail
last year the U.N pledged to change that
setting a goal to have at least 80
percent of the seabed map by 2030. but
one of the best tools to do that is side
scan sonar and historically there's
always been one big problem that
environment is so harsh that these
sensitive instruments typically can't
survive it but we think we've developed
the technology to make that happen the
only way to know
to go okay there is a necessary
claustrophobic element to any deep dive
Wright has been sardined in the subs so
many times that she's even got a
nickname
you don't
but this trip is different even for deep
sea Dawn this is extraordinarily dude
she'll be passing through more than four
times the deepest she's ever been before
and when she gets to the bottom of
Challenger Deep she'll be experiencing
with a hundred thousand tons of pressure
on the outside of that submersal
Surplus this is the LF the hatch is
secure life support is running I have a
green board I'll get in here
soon the ocean consumed them as if they
were swallowed whole
Wright's love of the ocean started in
her home in Maui
where the waves appeared every bit as
welcoming as the sea of stars above
when did you want to be an oceanographer
do you think when did you really want to
it was at the age of eight because it
was partly fueled by the Apollo 11
Mission if those men could land on the
moon I thought well why can't I go the
opposite direction and explore the
oceans but back in the 70s and 80s there
weren't many oceanographers who were
women
fewer still we're black were there
obstacles when you were coming up when
you were growing up all kinds of
obstacles I spent several years at Sea
as a marine technician and they were men
on the ship that I was on who didn't
believe that that women should be there
that is a story an age-old story it is
still an issue all of that though was
about to be eclipsed by her arrival at a
place void of judgment and Prejudice
bottom of the ocean done here it is
out of the Gloom there it was
surface LF depth one zero nine zero four
at bottom yeah all right
congratulations oh wow what an image
down there thank you thank you Victor
every second at the bottom was revealing
almost two revealed what what is that oh
that is artificial humans themselves may
be foreign to this landscape but sadly
our trash is not to Bubble it's a
freaking bottle isn't that something
it's a bottle as soon as we get here not
as pure an experience as she'd hoped for
perhaps but her disappointment soon
turned to excitement oh look at this
looking good that first of its kind side
scan sonar so many feared would give way
under the ocean's unrelenting pressure
humped along as if it was mapping a
Shallow Lake those are interesting
features most explorers will tell you
that there is one constant about pushing
the envelope dropping surface weight
ascending and that's that there's never
enough time
after 10 hours beneath the land of
sunlight air lungs deep sea Dawn
resurfaced returning to the pitching
deck of her research vessel where the
real work of analyzing her research had
now only just begun good job that smile
on Dawn Wright's face however was all
for her mom that what was encouraged her
to chase her lofty dreams even if they
lay at the bottom of the world what do
you think your mom would think
I think my mom would be extremely
relieved
somewhere High over the deepest spot on
earth Lee Cowan CBS News
and we just brought you to the bottom of
the ocean all in an effort to lift you
up I hope it worked that is our show I
trust it brightened your day lifted you
up if it didn't go ahead and watch it
again reruns totally free I'm gonna go
find some good news see you next time
[Music]
thank you